dude
[Music]
that should do
[Music]
it's been like on a day
it's been like kind of week and it's
only Tuesday it's been like kind of
month and it's only a little over half
over
hey everybody
uh hope everyone's doing well it's uh
yeah it's been a thing but yes uh 10th
anniversary I mean technically the first
of the month was the was the first
anniversary if you want to go by first
upload to the channel but we're gonna
treat the uh the whole month as that so
here we are and we've got a bunch of
stuff planned obviously we'll have the
normal back and forth with me and with
the chat and
um
and all that but I've got um some early
videos
um to show you and to react to which I
have not re-watched properly uh in a
long time I've uh I've got mad libs yeah
we'll have fun it'll be good I hope
everyone's doing well uh hello Ben
Pirates Molly Rowan Bruce Aaron uh
Dharma
Molly I might have said already Gozer
carowind Ms Wicked Wolf Angus
oh lots of folks good to see you all
happy 10th Anniversary Pop champagne
enjoy that
it's one year anniversary of my channel
on Halloween well congratulations in
advance
early videos are always fun well we'll
uh we'll see about that
watching your two recent videos back to
back were surreal use you seemed like
you were way more upset about the crazy
[ __ ] in Riverdale than you were about
the homophobic book Bannings well like I
made a point of keeping my cool as best
I could for the
um for the one on the book challenges
and the book Bannings but uh yeah
because you know part of that was
um
uh God I can think part of that was just
like not wanting to be dismissed for
being emotional
um but you know with the Riverdale like
just it's just
ah no earrings uh well I mean I'm gonna
be putting on headphones
um a little bit later when we start uh
watching stuff so I can actually hear it
um but uh but yeah I actually I gotta
put that one back in I take in so like I
have on this ear I have the three the
upper one I took out because I was
performing
um this past weekend for
um
uh
I can think and talk for Burlington
Pride actually you know what
now what give me a second here
let me think here
[Music]
let me see if I can show you
some of
the pictures from that
okay here we go
so like
all right let me move that the uh the
name that you see on is the that's the
watermark of the photographer but let me
hold on
ah this is uh this Jeep belongs to
Ginger Lolly that's her up in the front
there's me there's innocent Ivy there's
Jasper kinetic across the bar working
the legs
um Dominique Anjou was following the
back with
absolutely amazing hair
um so there was there was that but I
also performed
um and I did
uh
uh I did a fawn number
so because I had the ears on
um that was the reason I took the um
where am I uh the uh the upper
earring out for that uh there were
actually there were also there was also
a group number which so the group number
was after my solo and I did not have
time to change my outfit
for that and so as a result uh you know
dancing with the rest of the group uh is
a random fun
so
I get Amusement out of that
um I just thought it was it was
interesting like I said effect of um
uh of having having the time to change
my outfit but not
um not my makeup
uh
[Music]
uh congratulations on 10 years thank you
Logan
uh that's Ginger's Jeep nice yeah it's
it's uh it's it's actually a recent
um thing she had she had an orange car
kind of a ginger-colored car which we
called the Ginge mobile
um that unfortunately finally kicked it
and she bought the Jeep and the Jeep the
Jeep's quite nice
um
see here
sorry I think I missed something
oh
I see I see people were bringing up the
uh my
my upsetness about the slander of maple
trees on the uh
on the Riverdale so there's gonna be at
least two more videos that'll come out
of that she only described the first
five episodes of That season to me
uh but yeah there'll be two more of
those down the line
in the Fawn picture you look like you're
going to yell what do you want I'm
trying to sleep uh
every group number needs a random fund
yes it's uh I'm not just a content
creator I also create font tent
oh that was that was that that was awful
uh jeez
she didn't even get to the Sabrina
crossover I can't honestly at this point
I can't remember it's like a haze
um trying to remember what she told me
uh
but uh but yeah so that that was that
was the good part of my weekend we did
get rained on though actually rather
severely
um the tail end the first three quarters
or so of the parade was it was it was
cloudy it was overcast but it was fine
but then we we got poured on
um at the uh at the last stretch of the
of the parade
uh
I thought it was fair oh no Dharma
good clean Fawn for the whole family
okay so it's not just me
uh uh glad I was here for fondant no one
can ever take that away from me
you're on trial for a murder you didn't
commit who do you want to defend you
She-Hulk or Saul Saul he seems to
actually understand how the law works
that's that's when I when we get to the
end of
um
when we get to the end of She-Hulk I'm
gonna I'm gonna make make my case I'm
gonna make my case for why how
inaccurate the legal stuff was actually
matters
um not that I needed to be super
accurate but like it's so far out from
anything vaguely approaching actual law
that it is taking me an average schmuck
who knows very little about the law it
is taking me completely out of it
because even I'm going that's no that's
not no no and like shows like Better
Call Saul or if you want a comedy
example my cousin vizny shows that
courtroom accuracy can still be funny
I it doesn't have to hurt
storytelling and yet here we are
ah good grief
uh
Ben said that you would get him to
defend you I mean like I I love Jennifer
but she's not she's not proving her
herself very well as a lawyer right now
in that show
Piper at the gates of Dom versus Dark
Side of the Moon I prefer Dark Side of
the Moon Piper at the Gates of Dawn is
kind of uh that almost feels like an
oddity at this point in uh in Pink
Floyd's discography but then again like
I'm also weird because like I seem to be
one of you Pink Floyd fans who actually
likes Division Bell so what do I know
uh
uh I always carry a loaded pun with the
safety on oh my you people oh okay this
was the energy I needed this is the
energy I needed tonight this is this is
helping
uh my cousin Vinnie is a damn classic of
course it is it's great and I love it
when he's going through the witnesses
and each time he discredits one of them
I'm done with this guy
and the only one he's polite to is the
old lady he's just kind of a dick to all
the rest of them
real life actual law case man got
arrested for stealing his own urine
sample I mean especially if it was a
mandated drug test yeah I could see you
getting charged for that I'm currently
reading your book and loving it keep up
all the great Vibes and videos thank you
Spencer I appreciate that a lot
it's one of those things cops appreciate
about Hot Fuzz it actually addresses the
paperwork yeah right like anything that
like depicts a job especially one that's
actually typically shown
um in entertainment but actually gets
the people to do that job to go see this
thing gets it immediately kind of grabs
my attention just on principle
um
uh uh Mr gambini what are you wearing
well
um
you see uh I I had a suit because you
told me to get one and uh and it all got
covered in mud so uh I tried to take it
to the dry cleaner but the whole place
has the flu all of them all of them got
the flu so uh had to go to a thrift
store to get what I could find and uh
so here we are that's not the exact
lines but
have I seen the new Hellraiser trailer I
did
it's a little
um I mean granted it's a trailer and
trailers are cut differently from films
but it's a little jump scary for my
taste but
I'm liking the general vibe and we
haven't had a good Hellraiser movie
I guess most would say since the second
one
I think there's some fun to be had in
the fourth one personally but yeah we
haven't had a good Hellraiser moving a
long time
uh
I love She-Hulk the character but I love
a female character who knows they're hot
and can kick 12 kinds of butt whilst I
haven't seen the show I've uh
uh I've heard good things about it
um so like
you need to know what you're getting
into and they very much the creators
very much went and basically wanted to
create a sitcom and the thing is I love
She-Hulk in the comics but I love how
like the comedy aspects are not
um
detached from the uh from the comics in
the superhero nature they are integrated
with it it doesn't feel like they
bothered to integrate the legal stuff or
honestly
um much besides like well what makes a
good joke and it's just an it's an
approach to Comedy I generally don't
appreciate
in general I've gone off on this before
like in my mind the best comedies are
almost always
stories that would still be interesting
stories even if you stripped every
single joke out of it and then adding
the jokes in makes it even better that's
actually kind of how I feel about
Ghostbusters because and I know that one
works without knowing the jokes because
that's been one of my favorite movies
currently my favorite movie since I was
about four and I did not get a lot of
those jokes for a long time and still
loved it
so in my mind the best comedies still
should be telling an interesting story
but you know it's a different approach
to Comedy to focus in and just try and
be like jokes we're telling jokes we're
making jokes what about the story the
story is an excuse for jokes
and like that's not an invalid way to
make a piece of entertainment it's just
it rarely results in anything that I
want to watch or anything longer than
five minutes like for me that's a
perfectly valid approach to take for a
sketch but if you want
hour and a half to two hours of my time
please have a story
you know that is interesting
had a rough morning had to wake up at
6am because they wanted me to arrive at
nine
that's never fun
uh I love the mon the monsters but the
film looks terrible like I don't I don't
know what they thought they were gonna
get
getting Rob Zombie to do anything even
vaguely associated with comedy because
I've seen his attempt at comedy I saw
the Haunted World of El Super bisto and
it's
awful it's really awful
it's so awful that like I still hold it
against the screenwriter because Tom
Papa who wrote the script for that movie
he um shows up on wait wait don't tell
me which is a radio show I like a lot
but I still get annoyed by him and part
of that reason is in the back of my head
I'm like you wrote that freaking movie
it's weird man the stuff that sticks
with you
uh
demel Brooks movies fall under that
criteria for you Vera it kind of kind of
depends on the movie because Mel Brooks
it that's a little bit of a different
thing because a lot of those are
parodies so the story is largely
dictated by what it is he is repping on
so
um that kind of I don't want to say it
exists on a little bubble but it does
kind of break my normal rubric
um in that
um it's building off an existing story
presumably an existing story that was
interesting before he decided to go
parody with it
um
and I do think that is kind of true I
think a lot of his weaker ones are often
doing parodies of stuff that maybe
weren't great in the first place like
the whole Dracula Den loving it is not
good and while it's not good for a lot
of reasons I think part of that reason
is that there isn't you know Bram
Stoker's Dracula which is what it's
mainly riffing off of wasn't that great
in the first place you know whereas if
you're gonna Riff on Star Wars the
quintessential Robin Hood story
um you know the old west stories those
are fundamentally interesting stories
some of which had entire genres built
around them so if you're just gonna take
that template and inject jokes into it
yeah
I get that it doesn't always work but I
get it
uh that was the only good thing about
the La La Land Moon night mix up Marissa
Tomei was finally validated uh
anyone catch Amazon's good night Mommy
what the heck is that
see you say that the first thing that
pops in my head is night mother which is
a play and I can't imagine if they
renamed it to that then like I got big
questions uh my favorite Mel Brooks is
Robin Hood Men in Titan Young
Frankenstein yeah in both cases I would
argue riffing on stories that are
interesting even without jokes now do
hit do his movies and his takes and his
structure work without jokes not really
he's reconfigured them to accommodate
jokes but the original works that he is
spoofing and riffing on can work
jokeless
if I can be serious from when my car got
broken into the other night and some
guitars I own got stolen also I've been
in my paranoid lately oh my goodness
Logan I'm so sorry
oh
that's rough
I know this movie was a while back but
what did you think of Peter Capaldi as
The Thinker I thought it was good I mean
I think he's good in general but yeah no
he was good that movie like some people
really went in for that movie really
hard and were like really like yeah this
is great like I had fun I enjoyed it it
wasn't
the most amazing thing ever
oh okay hey Angus thank you very much
for the Super Chat five dollars which is
that did I put in
okay no good I'm I'm off the hook I had
set something in the pinned comment that
like because I've still got some of
these the uh the Bean Boozled which any
given
um
Jelly Bean could be normal and tasty or
could be absolutely disgusting ten
dollars I'll do this
uh 20 I'll I'll hydrate I'm hydrating on
my own time as well but you know if you
want to encourage the process
but Angus your actual question what is
the best film set in the Middle Ages and
why is it Monty Python in the Holy Grail
that is right up there
um
so the first thing I'm going to say is
nobody get on my butt about it
technically being or not being in the
Middle Ages because I don't know where
that time where that where the cut off
actually is but like some movies that I
really like that are set around in what
people tend to think of as the Middle
Ages
um there's the movie the Black Death uh
which is is dark
um but quite good
um I it'd be at the tail tail end of it
but there is a movie called The Advocate
well that was the U.S release I think
year of the pig was the European release
that movie's great I love it it's
freaking weird it's got uh it's got
Colin Firth and it's got
um
Bill uh Bilbo in Lord of the Rings God
why can't I think of his name
um
not Balboa from The Hobbit but from The
Lord of the Rings oh God that's that's
that's gonna bug me someone's gonna
holler it out in the chat
um but like that one's great and um for
more lighthearted
um
I would say A Knight's Tale
so good good night mommy is a remake of
a film about two kids who become
convinced that their mother whose face
is covered in bandages from an operation
isn't their real mother oh well that's
horrifying I will not be watching
excuse me I will not be watching that
ah
there are 69 people watching now nice
nice uh Ian Holm thank you God
huh
good grief I can think
we would like to apologize for the fun
the subtitles those responsible have
been sacked
uh
John vinyls thank you so much and I
think oh that's British pounds I think
converted that is 10 bucks shoot okay
um
all right but it's what is this this
that's white which means this is
probably it's gonna this is either gonna
be coconut or baby wipes if I remember
the baby wipes aren't that bad
I don't know
that's baby wipes
the fact that these things like they
kind of like the scent gets in your nose
is one of the weirder things about them
baby wipes isn't that bad though
it is weird it is strange
um
ZN home also Ash and alien yeah but
anyway
um if anyone has the opportunity to see
that movie either The Advocate or you or
the pig whatever you've confined it
under that's that's a delightfully weird
movie
um Middle Ages is between the fall of
Rome and the Renaissance well see now
that's already out of the problem
because when Rome fell is also a matter
of some debate but yeah I I I get your
point
uh you don't have to think you're pretty
thank you Gozer you get it wonderful
uh
so to recap the last couple months of my
life I got coveted my dog passed away
after waiting for me to come home and
some of my guitars got stolen Can
someone say rotten luck so um
like
this month especially has been bad like
across the board for like almost
everyone I know I don't know anyone
who's having a good month right now
but um
I joked
to Liz is like every planet in retro
retrograde
yeah
um six of them are
I'm not like super into astrology but
like somehow I it feels like oh yeah
that freaking tracks including Mercury
that little son of a [ __ ]
you plan on watching the devil's hour or
starring Peter Capaldi with Stephen
Moffett as the executive producer I
do not know what that is so
at present
I must say no cause I'd have to look it
up
took an art history classes spent way
too much time on the Renaissance in
Jesus imagery uh
be nice if they could bring up the fact
that uh one of the main proponents of
that image of Jesus I.E Leonardo da
Vinci
based it off one of his boyfriends
just saying
uh
I retire for what five minutes and it
all goes to [ __ ] the queen
oh I've seen some good Queen related
jokes in various places
uh
I saw a meme that says when will Mercury
be out of the microwave
ah good grief
your nails are pretty thank you I need
to redo this one because that that one
the Polish came off but yeah it's it's
holding on the rest
uh let's see
by the way astronomy is the study of
space did I say astronomy I meant to say
astrology
I don't know
Sunday was my 71st birthday oh happy
Bay Cali that's wonderful
congratulations
what do you think of TV shows such as Dr
Phil and Jerry Springer never had any
interest in them
never did and at this point especially I
think they're honestly kind of harmful
uh in particular to the um to the people
who appear on it and just kind of in
general
um because like anyone who appears on
that you're
you're just going to be paraded out as a
spectacle and maybe there are some
people who are ultimately okay with that
but like I don't think that's healthy
especially with someone like Dr Phil
which purports to like here let him help
you in a public setting because that's
good for therapy
yeah and then there's just what they
chose what they choose to
focus on and highlighting the
perspectives that again especially more
so Dr Phil and Jerry Springer not that I
think Jerry Springer is great but Jerry
Springer Jerry Springer doesn't really
pretend to be useful or helpful it's
just a sideshow whereas Dr Phil like
purports to actually help people and
no
absolutely not
uh
talking about Mercury have you seen the
dumb Tick Tock craze playing with
Mercury no I have not that one has
passed me by I'm on a better side of
tick tock than that
uh Watchmen spin-offs were a bad idea
but I'll be okay with one center around
the giant squid I'm not sure you can do
much with that because the giant squid
was and was artificially created like
what do you even do with that
no you said astrology but I uh won't be
obsessed if astrology is that horoscope
stuff astronomy is the study one yeah
yeah I know
last time I heard about anything from Dr
Phil was when he had the
the what I don't even want to know catch
me outside outside I don't
I don't know what that was I don't know
I don't care
at least Jerry Springer gave us a
musical that's true
Dr Phil isn't even a doctor I heard I
think he is but not of what everyone
thinks hold on
now I want to check that
Dr Phil
oh he does hold a doctorate in okay
here's the thing he does hold the
doctorate in Clinical Psychology but he
ceased renewing his license to practice
so he is a doctor in the sense that he
earned a doctorate
but he
um he he is not licensed to practice
which is why he has to keep a show going
because if he packages it as
entertainment he doesn't have to be
licensed to practice psychology
think think about how messed up that is
for just a hot second
that someone who
would be required in a private
one-on-one session to have a license to
offer psychological evaluation or help
to someone
stick them in front of a camera they
don't need to be licensed
that's messed up
is part of your dislike towards the
queen and House of the Dragon left over
from your feelings on me and Earl and
the dying girl I didn't even recognize
her so no
next week I will be moving out of my
small town in southern Texas and small
studio apartment uh in the gay epicenter
of Seattle
to a small studio apartment in the gay
epicenter of Seattle so excited to
finally live my best career life yay I'm
happy for you Renee that's that's
awesome
that is awesome
uh
I think he needs more practice well
practice makes perfect
I think most men need a little practice
don't you Mrs peacock
sorry
there we go
when will we be playing Mad Libs I don't
know why don't we laugh at um
the nonsense that I started doing at the
beginning of this channel for a little
bit so hang on let me get that up and
don't start right off the bat
all right
so this uh I have not re-watched
properly in a while this is the very
first scripted short that I shot this
was the first one that was uploaded back
when this channel was originally
supposed to be scripted shorts
[Music]
I
[Music]
am a geek
I'm not a nerd
I'm not a dork I'm not a dweeb
nerds Are Scholastic overachievers dorks
are perpetually awkward in social
situations and dweebs
well I think dweebs were hunted to
Extinction in the 1980s but I am a geek
so that
that opening
part of a
of a stand-up set
that I did when I was in New York
um
I forget where I went with it from there
because like that it dive it diverges at
this point for for this uh scripted
thing but yeah that that was originally
uh that was originally part of a
stand-up set
uh all right what else we got oh God so
yeah this this also has clip so there's
Random clips dropped in at various
points some of which come from later
episodes the reason for that is because
Nathan uh who's playing Dave the um the
lead character here
he did not memorize this entire
monologue I wanted this to be one
continuous shot uh I was not able to get
that because he kept flubbing the lines
so to cover the cuts I inserted stuff
like this and yes this was an actual
video store that was in operation at the
time it's not now and proud of it there
are more of us out there than you might
think a geek is someone with a passion
okay oh we've got random people
so that uh that is actually that's my
kiddo's mother
um
reading the nodwick Chronicles with a
pack um that's a couple of friends that
I knew
um that so kind of a roundabout way they
were con they weren't involved in local
theater but they were connected to it
um so actually for something Beyond a
mirror interesting
[Laughter]
oh I don't put my kiddo on camera
um
but I did then because
you know
I don't think she was even one yet
and I figure like
I don't think this this is some this one
shot and like I got clearance from her
mother to to do this and film it and use
it and you know we we she knew I was
doing this but um I I don't put my kid
on camera now and I won't but
there you go
from from over 10 years ago because this
was shot during the summer so yeah she
she was not yet
she was not yet one
oh goodness gracious it was actually so
cute that she put a sonic screwdriver in
her mouth anyway their hobby they're the
big ones Star Trek geek the Video Game
Geek the comic book geek but it can be
I okay this was a random drop in
that I grabbed
um I don't think I think I just realized
I wanted something and so I printed this
out this Klingon recipes thing that's me
you know in a wig
over up over a pot of boiling water with
nothing in it
um but yeah oh God
oh wow this uh this takes me back
I was I was oddly proud of the fact that
I used uh proper Klingon font for that
almost anything I can't
I think I actually printed out actual
recipes
there for like actual Klingon recipes I
can't read them now it's too it's too um
too low def knowing why She-Hulk can
change okay so
I I wanna
I just want to put this in here so the
shirt he's wearing he almost always wore
one of my shirts because I had all the
geeky shirts so that one's not super
geeky but I like it anyway so that's
quadruple tree which is a Mitch Hedberg
joke if you don't know Mitch Hedberg he
was a comedian who was amazing and
passed away way way way too young
um but yeah perform at will well regular
Health Okay so we've got Nicole at the
piano
um who we'll do at least one more so
you'll get you'll get to see her better
she's one of the other main leads
um and she could actually play the piano
she was uh she was a school music
teacher not matter to you but it matters
to us
so that there we go with some more
friends chasing uh chasing a child out
the door with a lightsaber because yeah
random geeky nonsense
that was actually the uh the wife and
the kid of the guy we saw playing people
who geek out about things
want to live them horror movie Geeks
like to make their bloody home movies
to cover
um
and yes that's cat that's ketchup on
this massive freaking knife it's packed
away somewhere that thing is absurd that
knife I've still got it
um
oh boy
so all right let's keep going
a truly dedicated fantasy geek might
write a few Harry Potter fanfics oh I
wish I wish I hadn't cited Harry Potter
there but if we pause for Nicole to
to pet the uh Tibet chameleon my dragon
um okay so like even at this point I I
had specific geekdoms planned for each
of these characters so like Nicole
um her character Kathy
um she is a fantasy geek a Star Trek
geek and she's the big reader of the
group
um Nathan who's playing Dave he's a he's
a movie geek that's that's his big thing
and also Star Wars
um Matt which was the character I played
was uh was a video game geek and a
doctor who geek were the main things
and somebody oh and we've got random
people playing Magic the Gathering in
the background again pulled from uh it
was like dungeon master who spends all
of their free time detailing a dungeon
this
this is from my book uh long before it
was a book this is my rough sketch of on
the uh on the left is the interior of
the dragon's breath
um
which is which is a location that comes
up and on the right is torbeck that is
the city uh which I had someone who's a
much better artist than me Redo for the
book proper
um but ultimately the uh the map of of
the Dragons of the ground floor of the
dragon's breath ultimately I didn't need
but oh it was in Dragon's campaign
and there's my world map with with like
Qatari was like what I originally called
it I think I ultimately decided like
just just drop it I couldn't think of a
name for the continent I actually liked
um so now and now it's just the lone
continent
um but
there's
there's my rough sketch because yeah
that's how long I was working on that
damn book
oh good grief
uh drawing Maps writing ancient texts
all right so that's a notebook tonberry
that's oh that's my book of Nod I think
that's just got dialogue scribbled in it
and accounting for every possible
outcome
another uh Community Theater person
well that person might be a serial
killer Okay so
I I like redecorated a lot of stuff in
the house so like normally that Lord of
the Rings poster
um over on the left and that sword
um to you know over on the over his
shoulder those weren't normally in the
kitchen
but I put them there for the sake of
this shot just to make it feel more
drenched and geekiness than the house
already was because actually at the time
I was living there my geekiness was
pretty well
um
contained to the the designated geek
cave where most of my stuff went my
point is we care about these things to a
level that you may think unhealthy more
Random clips from later episodes but
look around is it really so different
from the sports fan the car Star Wars
poster that I just bought and pinned up
the Reality TV Junkie of course they'd
never own up to be in Geeks but this
isn't about them this is about those of
us that wear the label with pride you
think you know what okay
so those two pieces of Art
were actually done by Nathan's brother
Caleb
and those show up in like the
proper uh opening credit sequence
because this doesn't have the proper
opening credit sequence as the first
episode
um but this was these were stylized bits
of art of each of the characters I mean
this is just the one for for Kathy and
for Matt
um there's a different one for Dave
which we'll do one more episode you can
see those too oh boy we're like you
think you can spot us you think we wear
Star Wars t-shirts talk through our
noses and stay up late on the internet
chatting chatting about how Spider-Man 3
was the worst again that that's me with
an empty bag of chips being sure to put
way up top worst movie ever
and I think
that might even be an IMDb review
um page from the time that I have pulled
up
I'm not sure maybe
I think it is maybe not I can't remember
movie ever you're wrong we've got the
sound is so bad the sounds inconsistent
the the camera's a wobbly mess this is
not good it's kind of fun to re-watch
but it's not blend in we live among you
and you don't even know it
we bag your groceries we do your taxes
we teach your children
we are Geeks and we are everywhere
I kind of yanked from um
Fight Club a little bit there with that
yeah and there's there there's all the
peoples
oh good grief let me come back see if I
missed super tests oh I have missed
several
um
Supreme Omega uh hope you are well
question uh
is isn't will they won't they romantic
tension can be more boring than stable
couples for me I don't think Ross and
Rachel has aged well
um
I don't know if it's inherently more
boring than stable couples it's
certainly more common and way more
played out than stable couples are
um because stable couples almost never
get shown so I don't think well they
won't they as inherently more boring but
it's boring it's more boring by
oversaturation as I think what I'd say
about that
Brandon Stotts thank you so much ooh
twenty dollars hydrating
more than a sip is what it'll be at that
uh congratulations on 10 years here's 20
to encourage another 10. thank you
Brandon I appreciate that immensely
worst movie ever yeah any thoughts on
Grant Morrison's X-Men run I don't think
I ever read I I'm actually not sure if
I've ever I know of a lot of stuff Grant
Morrison's done I don't think I've
actually read anything they've written
like front to back
I don't think I have
uh and here we see the wild geek in
their native habitat
yeah yeah
pretty much
I remember watching uh that TV movie
about the dangers of d d with Tom Hanks
in the in the 80s wasn't that like
Monsters and mazes something like that
uh question what's your thoughts on the
look of Ruble Bernstein and follow-up do
you think you could rock it
uh I don't know what that is hang on
Google help me out here
um huh
I can't rock that mustache mustache is
not a good look on me
the outfit the outfit I could work I
could work that outfit I'd not the
facial hair though John vinyl oh
that's that is also I think adjusted for
um
U.S currency
um
there we go
let's still re-watch your shorts every
now and then ah thank you Miss Wicked
Wolf sing goddess the tale of fierce
love between the glyph witch and her
beloved that Fierce love that shook our
aisle to their Stony roots and changed
the heart of a once doomed pair of
sisters one owl and one Raven
not even entirely sure what I just
recited there but
I like it I like it it's kind of good
it's Gotta Go it flows well
scans well
feels good in the mouth
I put that really weird it's awkward now
moving on
uh
last night you were unhinged a wild
Untamed thing
you frightened me
do it again
[Music]
oh I need to re-watch Adam's Family it's
really good it's really good you look
good with the Johnny Depp facial hair
but then everyone does yeah like that
that's the thing about the Johnny Depp
facial hair everybody actually looks
good with that but I can't grow that
uh so yeah
uh let's see I I don't know how we got
to uh to tons of um
Adams Family Quotes but I'm living for
it
oh is that is that what John vinyls
thing was from was that like maybe from
the second one because I know the first
one much better
just a modern woman trying to have it
all loving husband a family it's just
I wish I had time to seek out the dark
Forces and join their hellish Crusade
that's all
um
what's uh what's the best atoms do you
all think I mean I I guess Gomez
Ral Julius Gomez just oh
all right
um all right we'll do one more of these
I'm just trying to decide which one to
have it be I oh
okay I think it's got oh damn it it's
gonna have to be the tournament fighter
one
oh crap
uh I worry that uh that some of these
jokes have not aged well oh excuse me
but we'll see we'll see
so this was the second episode ever did
and here's the actual opening credits
proper with the theme and everything
because I've had this theme
Forever This theme was actually made by
the husband of a friend of my kid's
mother
so
um I like I added a superhero background
but that's that's that's the artwork of
Dave and it's sort of a superhero form
um and because he's a movie geek he's
got a movie reel on his chest
there's Kathy and becomes you know Elvin
with the dragon how she got the coolest
started
and there's me with short hair as Matt
in a sort of a cyborg uh
cyberpunky looking deal
[Music]
so actually hold on let me
let me get rid of my face so you can see
Kathy halfway decently there for a hot
minute
ah good stuff Caleb Caleb I don't know
if he's still drawing he's good
okay oh God
so the music you are you are hearing now
is also music from the same guy who does
the um who did the the main theme for
Council of Geeks and I also had him
um throw together some
um
the tournament fighter Style music for
me you're gonna hear
um
you're gonna hear like fighter uh
uh sounds and like yells and whatnot and
those were mostly provided by my kid's
mother and by Nicole who you'll see in a
minute
new tournament fighter
yeah
impressive breast physics
ah yeah they've got a nice jiggle on
some of the curvier fighters too
oh
impressive breast physics
oh dear
oh dear oh dear
how's the game play
I don't know
I turn it on in the opening cinematic
starts I get hypnotized and then it just
goes into demo mode and I can't stop
watch
there's been a gameplay and Fighters
This female heavy always suck
usually
price consideration
how do you figure
you know what's kind of weird with
throwing me off is seeing myself in
these These Old glasses frames that have
basically have no frame it's just like
the stuff that put in my ears and it's
just the lens free-floating there so it
looks like I'm not it looks as little as
possible like I'm even wearing glasses
like as somebody now who takes a lot of
pleasure and having a lot of very
noticeable frames it's weird to see to
see myself like that
um back then it's odd it is odd
well it's like porn you don't expect
Oscar caliber acting just great
titillation you trade acting for boobs
you're doing the same here with the
gameplay
not sure how comfortable I am at this
point comparing
uh basically a dead or alive style
tournament fighter to porn
that feels like a cheap jab I'm not sure
it's an unaccurate one
but you know
oh my God I don't know if I'd go so far
as to compare it to porn
okay maybe that move
possibly her Victory pose
hey guys
what the hell is
oh my God
why is her breasts bouncing
independently of each other when she's
not even moving
I don't know but it's
Strangely Beautiful
Nicole was such a good sport because
like the character of Kathy
um is gay which was part of how my 30
year old brain thought it would be okay
to justify
um
her ogling
these uh these characters as much as the
guys are
uh Nicole was a good sport to put up
with my nonsense
yeah
and
[Music]
wait for it
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't know like I'm laughing a lot I
don't know if it's actually funny or
it's just me remembering like filming it
and just thinking oh my gosh now like
quality wise I think this came out much
closer to what I had envisioned than the
first one did
yeah there we go
that's right my kid's mother got a craft
Services Credit
because she made she made food for us
oh excuse me
good grief
uh
it's surreal hearing this music among
these visuals yeah it's oh boy
they have huge trucks salon
sexy fight noises yeah basically
basically yeah
DOA did have a Diego physics slider I
forgot that Anita sarkeesian has entered
the chat oh she'd have my head uh
uh one minute and then I'm
well I'm like the first off what
second the
F
uh
uh it is actually funny to me at least
well I'm glad some people think so
uh you gotta get the crew back together
not really viable like Nathan I could
maybe pull he's a pain in the essay get
a hold of because he's barely on social
media at all I think I'd actually have
to go to the um
I would have to go to the farmer's
market because he sells uh he's a
blacksmith and he sells stuff there
Nicole that that candidate Nicole Nicole
moved away Nicole is on an island in the
Caribbean now I forget which one
um so yeah uh getting us all physically
back in the same space I don't think
that that'll that'll ever happen oh we
got more
uh super chats thank you very much
Freddie gormac Smith congratulations on
10 years you've quickly become one of my
favorite pop culture YouTubers
especially when it comes to Doctor Who
thank you
thank you I appreciate that a lot
a youngest oh boy that's uh that's a
hydrate
whoo
do you have a favorite 80s 90s kid type
sci-fi such as The Last Starfighter et's
excluded
um
the thing is if you're talking 80s and
90s I like the Fantasy around that time
a lot more than the Sci-Fi
because like the fantasy you were
getting stuff like
um like Labyrinth Dark Crystal
um
and even stuff like Conan the Barbarian
which I didn't see when I was that age I
saw much later but the Sci-Fi
a lot of the Sci-Fi didn't really grab
me at the time to be honest I was kind
of
I was kind of like a star wars only
Sci-Fi fan for a little while uh
definitely through the 80s and through
most of the 90s now that I think back on
it
uh Aaron oh no questions just happy
anniversary well um you did I appreciate
that greatly but you did contribute at
the 10 which means I'm pulling another
Bean out of this cursed box all right
what is this this is either
hang on
that's either gonna be
oh crap
that's either gonna be butter popcorn
or rotten egg
um
okay
Arrow
oh
ah
that's the worst thing about the bad
ones
is they take a minute to hit you
and so like by the time you realize what
it actually is
it's coated your tongue God damn it
you remind me of the babe
with the power power Voodoo you do mommy
of the babe
so my baby
crying hard as babe could cry what are
my thoughts on Masters of the of the
universe
I I nostalgically love it
I have not re-watched it in a while
because
frustratingly Frank langella has faced
some credible allegations in the last
year or so
um that makes me uncomfortable which is
really because I love Franklin Joe he's
an amazing actor and he is the reason to
watch that movie because Skeletor is
freaking awesome in that God
damn it
ah
it's right up there with not being able
to watch
uh
uh Usual Suspects anymore because of
freaking Kevin Spacey
have I read mistborn nope never heard of
it
too bad you can't smell them and detect
the fragrance you can't you really it's
sealed under the candy coating so you
really can't tell
you're saying is beautiful thank you uh
oddly
like this has got this this sounds like
a line but I I actually have had this
verified by other people
I sing better
after the equivalent of a glass of wine
or a shot
um because I get less self-conscious I
actually can sing semi-decently assuming
it's in my range but
um I get very self-conscious because I
know I'm out of practice but you know
you get a drink in me and I suddenly
don't care as much and so I'm not a
self-conscious and I am I'm better
I'm better I like to to get that back
without drinking uh without hydrating uh
I I'd have to I'd have to get back into
practice and I'm just I'm not
tell us more about your friend who's a
blacksmith at the farmer's market what
Nathan
um I don't know where it is right now I
actually have a bottle opener that he
made
um is is just is a laid-back guy he was
in um he's in kind of a madrigal's band
I don't know if that's still going he
was in that with his partner who I think
who I think they moved in together I
think they're still together I haven't
seen him in
since like maybe the start of
um
uh the start of summer so I haven't seen
him in a bit
uh have I seen the Wednesday trailers
I've only seen the first one
eh
looks like Wednesday actually probably
the kills are maimed someone in the
trailer for the new Tim Burton Series
yeah I saw that like that doesn't bother
me it's just not quite Landing right
with me
uh uh Stephen Baldwin's a donut too he
is but he wasn't a big part he wasn't as
big a part of why I liked the usual
suspect so he that didn't bother me as
much
uh
uh maybe just have to resign yourselves
to almost everyone was an [ __ ] so we
can enjoy flicks I know not a great
choice but um
what am I doing the patreon questions oh
that's actually I didn't set a time for
that because we're because we're gonna
go along actually you know what
um why don't why don't we do that now
since we've already done the cut off and
I'm not taking new ones so I'm gonna
jump over to the to the Discord right
now to take uh patreon supporter
questions
um I hadn't thought of when I was gonna
do that all right uh here we go
first up when did you first see this as
a possible full-time job
before I even started the channel if
you're asking me when I first
realistically saw it uh probably towards
the end of 2018 I thought maybe I could
make this work but like
the ambitious and somewhat narcissistic
part of my brain like right off the bat
like I'm gonna make this my living
having no idea what I was doing and what
I initially started doing not holding up
at all
but
um but yeah realistically I started
thinking about it tail end of 2018.
there would be uh about another year and
a half before that would happen
have you ever tried the canned water
called liquid death
no
what what is what
canned what what
hold on
liquid Dev
they quit Death Mountain Water murder
your thirst what the
what the hell is this
canned water company
why
what
hold on
water source from the Austrian Alps
where it's canned
it's also got sparkly but it's just
water
uh
okay I guess they've also got some uh
some carbonated stuff like what
oh when they also make nfts so screw
them even for a novelty
when reviewing a new season of a TV show
what makes you decide whether to review
them Episode by episode or as a season
as a whole it honestly a lot of it
depends on what my expectations are
going in that's something that'll make
um on a case-by-case basis
because it has to be something that I'm
pretty confident I'm going to see
through to the end of the season and
that I'm reasonably confident I'll have
things to say about every episode
um and so that's why generally I only
commit to doing it on stuff that I'm
pretty confident about so that's been
you know some of the Star Wars stuff the
Marvel Stuff Game of Thrones and some
things like that whereas other stuff uh
and and even some of that I have bailed
on after a couple of episodes or at
least bailed doing the reviews if not
bailed on the show so like I don't make
a full commitment even if it's my
initial intent but it it largely has to
do with uh it also has to do with how
are these being released because like
since Netflix does the binge thing
there's no reason to go Episode by
episode it's all available at one time
so it only really applies to stuff where
it's coming weekly anyways like on HBO
Max or whatever the hell that turns into
next next year and uh in Disney Plus
um but yeah Case by case ever had a
staking kidney pie I have had meat pies
I don't think I've had steak and kidney
uh have you tried Marmite uh I can't
remember if you received it when you
were getting UK snacks and food Etc uh
Marmite was not included in the UK
snacks that I was sent so no I have not
tried marmite
uh is it mulled cider weather yet sorry
mold water yep I'm going deep tonight
um it actually yes uh it's it's it's
been overcast it's been rainy it's mold
cider season although I am you know just
just regular water tonight
uh let's see what's up next uh when you
first filmed Council of Geeks were you
going with two guys a girl in a pizza
place Vibe
um if I was it was by accident because
I've actually never seen that show
so possibly but not on purpose
uh am I ready for the spoopy season I
think so uh my kid's excited my kid
my kid uh is intending to go as Peridot
from Steven Universe and her mother who
is
is all in is pulling together an outfit
hair and all it's it's it's gonna be a
thing
uh what is the airspace of an unladen
swallow is that an African swallow or
european swallow
uh if you like pops tart if you pop
stars
if you like Pop-Tarts what's your
favorite kind I get Pop-Tarts very
sporadically
um
and not very often I actually tend to
like the more uh start a chocolatey and
almost dessert style ones as opposed to
the fruity one so like things like
s'mores or the Oreo ones I like better
um when I have them which is rare
what are the best mythical creatures all
of them
all of them are mythical creatures are
wonderful and amazing and like I have I
have a personal soft spot for the haldra
because it's lesser known outside of the
uh sort of the Scandinavian regions
where it originates from but like
they're all good I love mythological
creatures they're great they're
wonderful what's the longest fanfiction
fan fiction you've ever read if any I
well hmm
see I was going to say I've never read
fan fiction that's not true
because I have not habitually and not in
a long time but I have read
basically pornographic fan fiction
but I kind of fell off that in college I
remember the one that broke me was I was
reading uh an X-Men
porn fanfic and like this and like this
was the days like freaking before
fanfiction.net or at least this was
stuff that couldn't be on fanfiction.net
because it was flat out porn
and it might have even been before the
site was a thing because I'm old
but I remember getting real ticked off
because because Rogue touched somebody
bareskinned and nothing happened and I
immediately closed it down and we're
like you don't even know these
characters at all so I got really mad at
the porn I was reading for not being
accurate to the to the characters that I
knew
um what was the longest I've no idea not
very long so because for the purposes I
was reading these things they only
needed to be I don't know maybe 10 pages
just saying okay I'm now I'm now back to
the main chat
uh
uh let's see here Peridot I love it yeah
the Claude
uh
see what else we got in here Pop-Tarts
are fun as a once in a while treat but
even as a little kid I like bagels and
lox and salami sandwiches mmm sandwich
never like PBJ I didn't either I would I
would eat jelly sandwiches but I didn't
I didn't really like peanut butter as a
kid
I really love your depiction of the FAE
and the mythical creatures used in
dreams of fire yay yay there are more in
the other one uh set in the same world
when I get around to it including some
new ones
um like I've got I've got trao
um in that one dryads show up again I've
got gargoyles yeah we've there's uh
there's some more in that one
um I think Trower the most notable New
Edition
uh in the in the next one which I don't
know when that'll be done I have no idea
uh oh John vinyls thank you very much
that's uh that is a hydrate level of
support cheers
that's good water
ever notice how stranger things plus Owl
House
explore similar themes and ideas
neurodiverging kids as Heroes found
family standing up to an oppressive
government a bully becoming a better
person Dimension travel I mean like do
these are not uncommon themes
to cover for characters in that age
range
obviously they are leaning into somewhat
different
um aspects whereas Owl House goes for a
bit more Whimsy and stranger things is
much more horror inspired
um but like those General themes are
pretty common in a lot of stories
um about characters in those age ranges
so yeah no I'm not uh I'm not partic I
don't think I'd ever much thought about
it but I'm not particularly particular
particularly
ah particularly
I had to just power through it surprised
by it
there we go
I'm all right
uh
so where are we here
Tolkien really should have written uh uh
about hot Health sex
uh go glorious AKA glorifenzel
uh oh dear lord
look there's plenty of Elf
um
naughtiness out there on the internet at
this point there there are some awesome
folks on that site that is uh just for
fans that do some elf stuff
uh I'll get around to doing that one of
these days we'll see
I eat PB J with banana power to you not
my thing
uh Supreme
Omega yes
saying it like that yes
would you like to see adaptation of
Wally as a flash someday on both film
and TV instead of always adapting Barry
highlighting the Legacy aspect of DC
uh I don't know why I decided to do it
all like that but uh I've said before I
really it's one of the things that I
hold the biggest grudge against
um
uh Jeff John's over was wiping out a lot
of the uh the Legacy
stuff and bringing back the
quote-unquote iconic versions of
characters iconic to him from when he
was growing it was it was so it was so
it was so creatively selfish
of him to basic basically go oh I don't
want to write the versions of these
characters that weren't the ones I was
reading when I was a kid me
so I I kind of I kind of hate that Jeff
John's did that
with DC
and
so like I would love for the Legacy
characters in general to be more of a
thing in the comics and especially in
the adaptations because it never comes
like Wally came up briefly in the flash
uh until he moved over to
um
Legends of Tomorrow were where he was
only for a season
but
um
yeah I
I would like to see Wally I'd like to
see a Green Lantern other than how
freaking Jordan
I'd love to see
um well I'd love to see Robin at all any
freaking Robin I mean like to be fair
the way they have been doing Batman
lately doesn't really lend itself to a
robin especially the Robert Pattinson
one which I did like that movie but I'm
not sure Robin would fit in that but
like I would like to see some Robins
multiple even
it's just
DC really had something
with the Legacy characters
they really had a sense of
history and growth and it also allowed
them to do one of the few things that
superhero characters never get able to
do which is
to stop to have an ending you could have
one of them close out their story and
but still have someone have the mantle
now I'm not saying that I should do that
with every character but like you at
least had the option to do it sometimes
and they used to and they don't now and
it's
it's really frustrating
uh do people go to the farmer's market
for Blacksmith work a lot uh I don't
know uh I can't imagine because I've
been to other farmers markets I don't
think I've seen blacksmith stuff I mean
though I've seen like Jewel jewelry work
stuff from like
I got this at a farmer's market
uh what the hell was that
um but no I I think uh Nathan's stuff is
the only thing I've seen the singing
blacksmith that's his stuff
it's good stuff
uh
damn to the depths whatever mutton the
thought of parlay
and now I want to talk like a pirate
I don't know why just feels like
something to do
how do you feel about Marcy's story in
the amphibia I don't like stories to
tell kids you can make new friends in
your new town or school because IRL
that's often not true
um I'll drop the pirate thing uh so
I don't know like the thing is
it's not always true
but I also think it's true often enough
that it's probably a comfort
for kids to hear and I think that
Comfort has value
even in the unfortunate situation where
it doesn't pan out because I think going
into a new situation thinking I will not
make any new friends here
like while you're definitely not now if
that's what you think going in
um I I see what you're getting at with
the question
that's not where I land
uh on something like that but I do
understand your perspective though I'm
I'm not in the same place
how tipsy would you say you are from who
boy to I'm out
um
I'd say I'm round about uh
right about there
Jon Stewart was the Green Lantern in
Justice League yes
one of the few instances but that show
is also like about almost 20 damn years
old might even be 20 damn years old
probably is 20 damn years old I am damn
old
um have you ever seen the old Quantum
Leap uh have any plans to see the reboot
I've seen I think I saw literally one
episode of Quantum Leap
when I was like nine I didn't understand
what was going on
I have not watched any since then I do
not particularly plan to see the reboot
one because I expect it's going to be
canceled
um and two it kind of got on my bad side
right from the trailer where like Okay
so we've got uh our new lead and the
Hologram helping him is a woman like we
used to be romantic why
why can't they just be freaking
co-workers
why why every time every time
God damn it
so no I don't currently plan to see it
what about Jay Garrick Jay Garrick is
underappreciated although he did also
turn it up in some of the arrowverse
stuff
was it
I think it was crisis on infinite Earths
he showed up
oh I can't remember now yesterday was
talked like a pirate Daisy you can get
away with it that's my excuse
ah
uh how come most pirates are Cockney
ever notice that like what the hell
honestly
because cockney's a real fun accent and
Pirates are fun
there you go
because it's either that or you're gonna
go real hardened on the r matey what is
it that ye be trying to do I'll make you
walk the plank and like that ooh that
Great's on the throat
doesn't Robin accidentally reveal that
he has an interest in Eugenics at the
end of the 1966 Batman movie
um
I would call that uh
uh a very odd reading
of the end of that movie Rowan I would
say Robin has a notion that is had by a
what is ostensibly a child who does not
fully understand the ramifications of
what he is suggesting and it is brushed
off by the adult in the room
describing that as an interest in
Eugenics I feel that is a um
inaccurate read
I see how you get there but I I think
you really veered off the road
how far from being fan fiction are words
or works like the good doctor they're
not fan fiction because they're
officially sanctioned
so
like they're they're just not how far
from fan fiction
as far as you can get because what what
defines something is fan fiction is that
it's unsanctioned
what to find something is not being fan
fiction is being officially sanctioned
like there isn't really a there isn't
really a gradient of that it's either
officially sanctioned or it's not
because like people will say something
like
this feels like fan fiction and use it
as a derogatory
for a piece of work
and that's something that I've I myself
have done and I try not to anymore
because fan fiction is no more
inherently bad than anything officially
sanctioned because fan fiction is not
constrained by what has the IP owner
actually signed off on there is much
more of it therefore there is much more
bad stuff just not necessarily as a
percentage but definitely by sheer
volume there's a lot more bad fan
fiction just because there's a lot more
fan fiction
but when people deride something as
feeling like fan fiction and they use it
as a derogatory that I don't think has
much meaning
I will kind of Stand by
um what I said about
uh rise of Skywalker in that the level
of escalation
felt a bit fan fictiony but not in the
sense that like I'd ever read fan
fiction that was like that but in the
sense of it's the kind of ridiculous
one-upsmanship escalation
that feels like it comes from an
unconstrained fanned mind when if it's
actually being put into a movie produced
by Disney it felt like somebody
somewhere should have gone slow your
role and nobody did
ah that movie was a mess it's very weird
to me now that my my uh review at the
time was broadly positive
all right trying to trying to catch up
what are some of your other favorite
lesser-known mythical creatures
um
I don't know I I kind of I kind of like
the little mischievous ones like uh like
your red caps and your brownies
uh
uh who was your favorite protagonist of
the four books of infinity train ooh
um
I would say God I can't remember her
name now
oh yeah Lake
Lake from book two was my favorite
I think they're all good uh actually
imagine if Doctor Who was French or
Irish now like we might actually get an
Irish doctor at some point but French
welcome to zetatis he's bigger on the
inside no
that was probably offensive
to uh to somebody
you think House of the Dragon uh has so
time has so many time jumps because it's
based on uh historical history it's
based off
historical history
fictional history and history of
stretches where nothing interesting
happens HBO Rome had a lot of time jumps
too I'm sure that's exactly the reason
why and basically people who've actually
read the uh the fictional history this
is adapting have said as much to me but
that doesn't do anything to change my
impression of when they work or when
they don't I can understand why
something's there but that doesn't mean
it suddenly works
uh
I just there's just random quotes
showing up uh that's showing up in here
and I'm loving it
first your return to shore was neither
part of our negotiations nor our
agreement so I must do nothing secondly
you must be a pirate for the pirate code
to apply and you're not and thirdly
the code is more with more wood called
guidelines than actual rules welcome
award the Black Pearl Miss Turner
ah that movie's so good
in uh Bionic Commando oh God are we
really going to talk about that that
twist yeah we are the consciousness of
the main character's wife was in his
mechanical arm biggest wgf moment I've
witnessed in my life as a gamer so far
see I didn't even play that game but I
read that I'm like no
No this must be like somebody's weird
twisting of what actually happened and
then I looked it up I'm like what
what
I usually interpret fan fiction as
unpolished at best and wish fulfillment
at worst like I I understand using it to
mean those as derogatories but again I
kind of feel that's unfair considering
that there's a fair amount of fan
fiction out there that's better written
than a lot of officially sanctioned
stuff uh
I should check out fan fiction for the
13th Doctor
on a completely unrelated note
ah
yes Vera was right about fan fiction
Doctor Who is basically fan fiction
he explained the ending of Batman 66 I
never seen it oh geez Okay so
I will try
oh some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb okay the ending
um the criminals come into possession of
a dehydrating device where you can
dehydrate someone to basically into a
pile of sand
um and if you rehydrate them they just
pop back up and they are themselves
again
and so the villains which are the
Riddler The Joker Catwoman and the
Penguin use this on the
um I think it's the security Council
anyways on the United Nations so all the
United Nation members and they put that
the sand of them in these uh these
little tubes
and they kidnap them and hold them for
ransom
and near after like the big climactic
fight this comedy character has just
been around called commodore schmidlap
he uh
he accidentally knocks over the vials
with all of the
um United Nations representatives in
them uh all over the place meaning the
sand has all gotten all intermixed and
so you know the so Batman and Robin have
to like they come up with a device to
separate the sand out and try and not
have a single grain of sand out of place
so that they can restore these people to
how that how they actually were and I
forget what Robin's exact line is but he
basically floats the idea of like before
we bring them back
is there anything that we can or should
do that would put them in a position
where they'd be better able to negotiate
peace for the world I forget his exact
line because it's been too long since
I've seen it and Batman basically going
no it's it's not our place to uh to mess
with nature
um and then they they uh they rehydrate
um these people and turned out they
pretty much got it except like the
brains have been swapped so like you
have like the guy was clearly the
English guy you know slamming his shoe
on the table which had previously been
established as something that I think
the Italian representative did uh and so
like there is a little bit of that and
they kind of shrug it off because like
well that's what the way it is now but
Robin I kind of suggested doing
something like that on purpose
um but anyways
I think that I think that covers it
as a resident resident
resident of Vermont
do you fear being attacked by Champion
or spillover from Maine's monsters
um I don't think anyone calls him
Champions just champ
um and no no Champs got our back we love
champ John vinyls thank you so much
Rey's mother was Palpatine's daughter
Martha
wait a minute what's her name actually
Martha
I'm gonna look that up now
because so help me
because either that's a really good joke
or it's the stupidest thing I've ever
heard raise
parents names
uh
uh Defan and
uh Mirror Mirror
okay so uh good joke then John nicely
done why did you say that name
thoughts on Torchwood Miracle Day still
haven't seen it
did you see the car the the fan cover of
Doctrine distress that raised money for
charity
I did not
Erin thank you so very much that oh crap
that's a bean
my last Super Chat was in Canadian
dollar so it wasn't quite 10 US dollars
so I'm hoping this will make up the
difference May the next Bean be better
well huh all right what do we got let's
see
what is this this
is either going to be
Tutti Frutti
or stinky socks thanks Erin
huh
it's Tutti Frutti
which isn't a flavor I love but that's
all right
ah
who's my favorite viewer
all of you I love you all
and I know that that's like
cheesy and generic but like
if you are watching this and hearing me
say it be it live or on a playback
I love you thank you
you helped make this possible
and
I can't thank any of you enough for that
so your daughter's costume are you just
getting her the outfit or will you do
green skin paint in a pointy wig too so
I've realized like since I don't think
I'm gonna show any more of the shorts
we'll do Mad Libs in a few minutes
um since I'm not doing any more of the
shorts I could actually take that off
um so
my kid's mother is putting it together
she's gotten most of the outfit put
together
um she's making the visor
and she is making the the wig
and
my kiddo has given clearance to have her
skin painted green which we weren't sure
she would do because she doesn't like
makeup but uh she seems to be prepared
to commit to this so yeah uh
unfortunately
for anybody tries to tries to ask uh
pictures of her will not be made uh
public
um
so you'll have to take my word on
how good the outfit is or isn't because
I don't share images of my kid
who had sex with Palpatine that was my
first question that's actually in many
ways kind of the biggest hole for me
and I don't just mean in a uh who would
want to wait because like I'm not going
to yuck somebody's yum but uh Morena
that dude never gave any indication that
he had the slightest bit of sex drive or
interest in anything that wasn't just
amassing power kind of way
like that's more where I'm confused on
that you've probably been asked a lot
but uh have you seen do you plan to see
dead end paranormal Park
um I'm trying to get the kiddo
interested in watching it she's not
biting so far or at least she wants to
do other stuff first
excuse me so I might try and cram it in
maybe next month because it'll be
slightly seasonal
um
excuse me but in addition to that
um I am trying to get in stuff that's
come out this year I'm trying I'm trying
over the next few months to anything
that I think is a shot at making my top
10 pieces of entertainment of the year
um at Year's End I'm trying to get in if
I haven't already seen it
uh early I meant when will you answer
the questions from the patreon thread oh
okay
um so yeah the the patreon
oh
maybe later this week
I'm not gonna promise I'm gonna try
I'm not gonna promise
especially considering I may not
remember I made that
claim
why what did what are my hands doing
all right where
where did I leave off uh here we go
kids mother is awesome yeah she does
pretty good Supreme
Omega
thank you for your contribution to the
cause
was it worth it to derail the spider
marriage so many times even after one
more day because they try to end it
several times in the 90s and it drove
readers away I
laughs
Marvel writers
have never liked the fact that
Spider-Man and MJ got married
um
like from the incident happened because
it happened because Stan Lee decided to
do it with the Sunday strip
uh with the newspaper strip and
they wanted to have continuity so they
rushed it in the comics they didn't like
it then and they never got on board with
it
but the fans did
the fans invested in them even if the
writers didn't enjoy writing Peter and
Mary Jane the disrespect
that was paid to that relationship and
that marriage and yes before one more
day
but even taking that into account screw
one more day holy crap
son ugh
oh
basically a lot of people in the Doctor
Who Twitter got together to sing it I
may have been one of them didn't ask you
if uh wanted to take apart because the
block function exists
uh
why don't you wear the costume to show
it to us because while my kid is quite
tall for her age she's not six feet tall
that's why I would tear through it
something that's been bugging me for a
while you said you find fully rendered
3D Graphics in game to be caused for
motion sickness care to elaborate
um so basically Logan
at this point like it's been a thing off
and on for ever
um but at this point especially
[Music]
um
anything where the camera is more or
less free roaming
so like if the camera is locked off uh
like say with your original God of War
trilogy
that's not a problem the issue is less
that it's fully rendered 3D graphics and
more that the camera is free roaming
because even if I am in control of the
camera which most of these games will
allow me to do
um the camera swinging around as I look
at things will set off my motion
sickness and it's not even just a matter
of high octane action oftentimes where
it starts to hit me the worst is when I
am just looking around an environment
just the way the the cameras swing
around I get motion sick
and it's gotten worse it's gotten worse
in the last few years I think the last
game
the last games that I played that were
anything close to that that I didn't get
motion sick on were probably the PS3
Wolverine game
which is that's a semi-locked off camera
um because it does pan but it's not
fully free roaming
um
and and
[Music]
um
um Uncharted 3.
so you know
like about a decade ago
at this point like I just it sets off so
harshly
it got it it got set off during The
Stanley Parable which like is really
low-key and but even that that set it
off I think it's real bad at this point
would you ever react to the fan cover
the way you did for real doctor and
distress
um
maybe not tonight don't ask me to do it
tonight
uh have you seen the second doctor
episode The Mind robber I think is his
best episode I have seen it but I saw it
like
14 years ago so I need to re-watch that
one
um my favorite has still been
um
Tomb of the Cybermen which has some
problems some part some aspects of that
have aged real badly but I still it's
got a lot of my favorite stuff
you say one more day I think one day
more from Les Mis
One Day More
another day another destiny
ah
yep I like lament I'm gonna next time
next time I don't have an audio book to
listen to
and I'm in the car by myself I gotta
crank the Les Mis soundtrack just belt
that
I used to do that in high school just
belt that soundtrack loved that
soundtrack
yeah
do you hear the people sing singing the
song of angry men
this is the music of a people who will
not be slaves again
[Music]
when the beating of your heart Echoes
the beating of the drum
there is a life about to start when
tomorrow comes
I could keep going but I don't want to I
don't want the I want the stream to get
flagged
uh
what's worse Christmas creeper back to
school commercials in July
Christmas creep because that actually
shows up like physically in stores the
back to school commercials that's
usually only on network TV and I don't
watch it so
weird one but your favorite dialect
design
um
I don't know
I got oh I don't know I kind of default
to the um to the series one dot like the
kind of rusty look that was introduced
in series one with Eccleston that's
partially nostalgic because that's the
first one I saw
uh did you mind me using my question as
an extension on my last commission
review I felt like I was violating
someone soon to rule out the questions
would be about you no I didn't mind at
all don't worry about that and I
answered it you'll you'll get to see
I second Ben's request for a reaction to
the doctor and distress fan cover not
today excuse me not today not this week
but someday please
ah
someday the days of men will end but it
is not this day
I have a better soundtrack for you blast
Hamilton I can't sing as much of
Hamilton though not as much of Hamilton
is in my range
some of it is
a lot of it isn't
uh the power cable generated an
electrical field to confuse their tiny
metal mines you might almost say they've
had a complete metal breakdown oh doctor
I'm sorry
yeah stuff like that Rowan was it's like
that's the tombs of the Cyber members
are what made me love the second doctor
I love him
it's amazing
I'm singing along here they can't
demonetize me I'm good to know
uh
uh let's see
last question for me have you ever heard
of the Mongolian metal band The hue
yes that is how it's spelled I highly
recommend they are really awesome
Mongolian metal band
you have my curiosity
since I intend to crash after this
stream you may have to like hit me up on
Twitter or something to remind me but
ah
my wife used the words from that song on
a protest sign during the George Floyd
protest in 2020 oh I think that works
once I miss from Catholic Services be
not afraid it's my favorite hymn but
I've only heard it once in any
Episcopalian churches oh I don't know I
don't I don't I wasn't I um
I wasn't raised in a church so hymns
weren't ever really a big part of my
life but I'll buy that I saw the Hue
live oh well
you got an endorsement as well Logan and
Caroline has good taste so
uh
I'm not doing the Hercules Mulligan
thing right now
uh what is the Christmas creep Christmas
creep is like it's so it's not like a
creep with Christmas like hey do you
want to sit on Santa's lap it's not that
uh it's like Christmas creeping in to
places where it has no business you know
when I was a kid
I'm old
um
I like I'm not the oldest thing in the
world but just at this point saying that
phrase just makes me feel old but when I
was a kid
the thing was it wasn't until after
Thanksgiving
that you'd see Christmas things
Thanksgiving was the wall that held
Christmas set Bay
and the wall fell
now it is up to Halloween to hold strong
and hold Christmas back
but there are cracks in the wall
and you see it leak through
you see the Jingle Bells in October
you get the idea
oh
John vinyls thank you so very much uh
Les Mis soundtrack is a lot less
complicated than Hamilton's to be quite
awesome yeah the Les Mis songs are not
particularly Wows the range on some of
them is a bit tricky but like as
compositions they're actually quite
simple
um but that's part of what makes them
work really well to be sung by Massive
choruses part of the reason Hamilton's
songs are a lot more complicated is
there is very little chorus work there
isn't a lot that like a mass number of
people are singing at a time whereas Les
Mis is full of that and you don't need a
complicated piece of music for it to
sound really good sung by a ton of
people
so I think that's just kind of a
fundamental difference there is that Les
Mis has so much chorus stuff and
Hamilton has almost none
sycorax Rock what's your pitch for a
doctor who musical um
i ooh I'd have to ponder that
I
that is my pitch for the return of the
dreamlord he forces the doctor into a
musical
of the Mind
there's the pitch somebody do it uh
I watched the Netflix adaptation of 13
The Musical it annoy me so much I felt
like I was being possessed by the
Nostalgia Critic
I believe the Hue did a song for Jedi
Fallen order
interesting
bless this holiday music it's joyful and
triumphant
uh
hate hate hate hate
lose entirely
I still don't like that movie but there
are like they're fun memeable moments oh
we were gonna do Mad Libs okay all right
I've been trying to catch up on the chat
but I realize I'm not gonna catch up
um so anyways how do you feel about
Halloween creep I love Halloween so I
don't mind it yeah I don't mind that
nearly as much I could be King George
for Halloween I do not have the crown
nor do I have The Robe although uh one
of my burlesque friends
did do a King George number
and it was good
are you pondering what I'm pondering
I think so brain but why are we ever
going to find rubber pants in our size
ah what do I think of Stacy's Mom it's a
dumb song but I like it again partially
because I have a burlesque friend who
performs to a Ginge performs to that one
uh writing advice do it daily if he can
set aside an hour and do it daily get a
make a habit out of it
um anyways anyway I'll John vinyls Eda
Titan below here
my prayer and need you have always been
there ah
[Laughter]
uh it's changing from God on high here
my prayer I can't sing that because I
can't do that falsetto
ham
I don't think I can
hear my prayer
falsetto is not my strength
in my need
you have always been there
ah but thank you John very much anyways
Mad Libs Okay so
we're gonna do at least one because I
said we would this is Doctor Who Mad
Libs still got these so the first thing
I need I need an exclamation
something that somebody would say you
know just
like oh darn Drax gadzooks
[ __ ] something an exclamation show me
what you got in the chat and I will pick
a uh one one that I like zoik's
I like crikey we're taking crikey
it will not always be the first one I
see but it might be we'll see uh I need
a place if you kindly
so uh now we are at a place I should
have sharpened this pencil
the same pencil I had in my hair for the
for the book Banning
video
xanadu's
Swindon Kyoto Kyoto roller skating rink
I like Swindon there's something there's
I don't know
Swindon sounds like a punch line and I
don't like nothing against I know
nothing about it but it just kind of
does uh I need a noun just any old noun
roof
foreign
pirate cat sock yarn torp
doctor spank is not a noun
spank is an action
control panel water
toxin door
um are any of these jump on jumping out
at me
um
hold on
um
you know what we're we're gonna do
dachshund
dachshund
I need another noun so I'll keep looking
uh see what we got here
please I like cheese
um and now I need a verb we already had
spank we'll keep it
uh and now I need
I need a part of the body plural I would
tell you to behave yourselves but I I
don't think there's any point in in
advising that
ah
so we're a part of the body plural
tit oh kidneys
oh kidneys if it's Doctor Who it's it's
got to be kidneys well actually hold on
what else we got bollocks elbow
tentacles thighs hamstrings
all right bollocks we'll do bollocks I
did appreciate kidneys though
um
all right I need
I need a name somebody's first name
boobs
thank you Sebastian I'm surprised it
took us that long to get there
[Music]
Donna Rose Vera Donna
uh uh you Donna Rory Cornelius
[Laughter]
mccavity uh do benchmarks oh
my cavity made me laugh so we're going
with that
cavity
uh I need a past tense verb
past tense of vibe
that's the kind of void I want I mean
toss that kind of void my way
I'd appreciate a good vibe
foreign
I I see that one Molly I'm not gonna
read it out but nice
flirted exfoliated gas flu baked
humped spanked well we did spank pull
axed oh yeah
uh
defenestrate
um
well we're gonna do prolaxed
uh
so
um
I need another verb
Dan Pope and I are such a fun volley he
is fun yeah
uh
so I'm on to another verb does not have
to be past tense this time a different
verb if you
please
John vinyls thank you worst music of all
time is either Love Never Dies glitter
and or music I recommend you take a look
at the Apple I'm not sure it's as bad as
any of those but you want bad Musical
that'll do it
uh
uh leap sleepy
yeet
all right yeet
oh all right I need a noun
a weird word noun
sounds like somebody's slurring their
words when they say they want something
now I want it now
yeah uh
catch Plum mushroom
uh Newt balls pajamas juice Statue of
Liberty tea cup
uh Kettle I like kettle we'll go simple
on this one
I do need another noun so you can keep
them coming
mole whisker ghost police box
noun
oh God that does that does sound like
Arnold Schwarzenegger doesn't it
oh
Dean Fine
uh I need an adverb from folks and this
and this is your uh this is your quiz to
see if you remember what an adverb is
uh
stealthily swimmingly
fluidly
uh
I rather like fluidly
I need a place
if you could
ah
it's a verb that can do addition right
that's exactly what it is Vancouver
Denmark Nepal Spooky Island Arkansas
Mojave
Baltimore Good Morning Baltimore
inside my living room
ooh Fraggle Rock
Donald Rock
and finally
adjective
go
ah
the Hamburg Philharmonic
hey that song So Evan much from above
baltimorean apologies Astrid I like that
musical uh
uh let's see what am I waiting for oh
adjective
um fluffy purple
vast persuasive
um
a tunnel ooh
squishy cozy closed analytical rainy
spicy ooh incomprehensible I like him
comprehensible
all right
we have ourselves a doctor who story
created part and part by you lovely
folks let's see what we got
crikey that's not good the doctor said
as we sped through Swindon he pulled his
Sonic dachshund out of his jacket pocket
and aimed it at the nearby hovering
cheese the cheese began to spank into
two human-like creatures
I saw one of the creatures
I saw one of the creatures bollocks take
form
oh my mccavity it looked just like mine
it should look just the creature's
bollocks look just like my bollocks okay
run the doctor pull axed and pulled me
away
that's us he added well future us we've
been so much as Yeet with ourselves it
will create a kettle that could tear a
hole in the space-time beam
damn
I fluidly looked back at Future us
wondering where in the Fraggle Rock the
doctor was going to get that
incomprehensible hat
[Laughter]
oh
I gotta remember that I have this more
often it's fun
oh
get to the Taurus I don't know that's
the doctor get to the Tardis noun
[Laughter]
in comprehensible hat as a Douglas Adams
story if it's not it should be
uh and the words of Thor another
oh
let me think
maybe one more hold on let me think
hmm
the next time the bath episode returns
oh God I it it has been
that's been a long time part of the
reason I don't do the I haven't done a
live stream from the bath
is because back when I did that I sell
the laptop it's the same reason I don't
stream from where I sit uh for my normal
videos anymore because now it's you know
the computer is fixed in place I do have
a Chromebook
so in theory I could do it from the bath
I don't know how good the I don't
I don't know if my mic will work with
the Chromebook though so the audio might
be crap if I try and do that I don't
know
I don't know
ah I don't know
I have a regular work named Thor I was
disappointed when I called out strongest
Avenger and he didn't respond
you should have said Point Break
uh
uh guess I should have said point oh
yeah see
there you go
full
access denied
God of Thunder axis denied son of Odin
access denied strongest Avenger access
tonight strongest Avenger access denied
damn it stock Point Break welcome Point
Break
nah
ugh does anyone remember laughter yes
yes I do
laughter is a wonderful
wonderful thing
excuse me
having done research apparently Thor is
cool with the X-Men so he's the least
dickish Avenger
yeah
Fair although there's been there's some
X-Men who have been Avengers Beast was
on The Avengers for freaking ages
uh you know you're on strong painkillers
when your colleagues at work don't seem
to be as annoying as usual that yeah the
tracks no yeah I remember someone
suggested uh someone on Twitter
suggested doing an edit of Terminator
which you don't show any of the future
scenes or giveaways that Arnie is a
robot before the get out scene
[Music]
that'd be interesting
I mean like you you'd know
going in
but bad musical Paint Your Wagon I'll
take your word for that
I don't know why you said Paint Your
Wagon and songs from cannibal the
Musical started going in my head
it's gonna be a split doing cool day
ah
anyways
so yeah no I'm not gonna not gonna do
another Mad Lib that one was good that
one was good it'll just that'll be the
only one
gonna wrap this up and carowind had
reminded me earlier to Hype up stuff
coming so like I remember like still
brain part work still
um so yes
tomorrow I will be streaming on Twitch
I'm still on Loop hero I'm gonna try and
uh get through the fourth chapter and
get it beaten
um we'll see if I can pull that off
um but that's that's what I'm gonna be
spending uh tomorrow's stream doing
maybe maybe
big maybe maybe I will have the first
three episodes of Andor scene and
reviewed that I do not promise because
I've got to finish an edit on something
else and then on Thursday is She-Hulk so
I don't know I think maybe what'll
happen is
maybe I'll do a review of the first
three I hate drop three episode five
um I think I'll try and have that if I
can get to them I'll try and have
[Music]
um
uh I'll try and have those out for Andor
on Thursday if I have the time to watch
all three and if I do that then She-Hulk
episode will be out on Friday
um
and then Friday I'll probably be
streaming more Loop hero if I don't beat
it on Wednesday if I do beat it on
Wednesday I don't know what I'll be
streaming and then Saturday Saturday is
the return of the MCU body count where
we do Captain America that will
hopefully
be ready for Early Access viewing for
patrons tomorrow
I think
that
that is everything
I think so
I think so
yeah
69 watching nice
does twitch require an app no it does
not
well if you do it from from mobile I
think it does but
um Verma computer no it does not it does
not require an app
oh
uh shot in the dark but uh have you seen
any more of Cobra Kai nope
um Liz is trying to get through some
more of it I still have not seen past
season three
at this point I've got all this other
stuff to do it's just not uh just not a
priority and yes uh thank you Carolyn
twitch uh 10 30 a.m eastern daylight
time tomorrow if you are able to join me
on my quest to do whatever it is that we
are trying to accomplish in Loop hero
bring back the world I suppose
betcha The Twist will be the world
wasn't worth bringing back pain it was
better destroyed
that would track with the tone and the
mood of the thing
anyway
uh yeah that'll wrap it up thank you for
joining me uh thank you for celebrating
10 years
I did not finish this particular bottle
of water
but that's probably for the best
this has been fun
thank you for joining me and I hope that
you
have uh a wonderful
rest of the day
and a wonderful rest of the week oh
I missed a Super Chat thank you thank
you Lewis I'm so sorry
uh John vinyls you snuck one more in on
me oh woof
ah
and also oh uh home body if you go to
twitch.tv Council of Geeks you'll find
um
that'll get you to the twist Channel
thank you for bringing that to my
attention Carolyn and uh yeah so John
vinyls you stuck one more Super Chat him
on me yes I've seen musical hell's
coverage of the Apple if you don't mind
me asking do you know anything about
Love Never Dies and or glitter
um only piss take reviews that other
people have done I saw Lindsay Ellis's
video on Love Never Dies and I've seen
Todd in the shadows is
video on glitter right
so I have not seen either
directly and I have no particular desire
to
so yeah
that'll do it
ah so I think I think now I think now
I'm caught up
uh thank you everybody have a great rest
of your day night week month
uh hey John JBL sneaking in last minute
love you too good to see you
um but yeah we are going to wrap it up
um it was good to catch up with you a
little bit John I saw John at Pride uh
Burlington Pride on Sunday that was nice
I haven't seen him in ages he's got
purple hair now it's good look
um but anyways thank you all and please
remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
my Kelly